this morning we are sharing a story of a
maryland violinist who has seen
firsthand how music can help a community
he's been performing for older people
for years jan crawford finds out why he
decided he could do even more to serve
during the pandemic
at practice you can hear the talent
not surprising considering alexander
strahn has been playing violin since he
was a kid
when i was 10 years old and my mom
surprise surprise wouldn't let me play
the drums that was my first pick
[Music]
what might be surprising given this
talent is his day job
i'm police officer strong
strong is a cop in prince george's
county maryland i think it throws people
for a leap because they're thinking wait
a second
why is there an officer here what are
you carrying oh you're here to play
but you don't really see you know cops
uh you know in uniform playing a violin
that's just not something you see not at
all
sees the violin as a way for people
especially seniors to find connections
it makes it feel like it's a warm
welcome environment that we're all
family and the music brings us together
those simple notes unlock powerful
memories for those senior citizens it
was in high school he started playing
for people in assisted living facilities
and in hospice after studying music in
college strong traveled the world on a
mission with music for healing
that all stopped with covet so strong
put down the violin for the badge
it seems so different you're you're a
violinist and now you're a police
officer the situations we go in are
arguably sometimes the worst of
someone's day
and when i played for in hospice those
moments i was part of it's arguably
probably the worst that that person's
had experience being able to play for
people in those situations helped
prepare me for
the grittiness of the job how so
because it's a hard moment to play for
someone
and their families surrounding them and
they pass away you so you really haven't
traded in the violin for the weapon
right you found a way to carry both
exactly
he saw the power of music while playing
for his grandmother who suffered from
alzheimer's
when i played for her
she
would sing sometimes cry one of her
favorites amazing grace
that was something she recognized yeah
something to recognize it's almost like
the fog of all alzheimer's lifted and
she was able to see again and then
the disease took her right back and it's
you had those that's so moving right you
had those moments with her i did
now playing in uniform strawn hopes
people will see officers as more than a
gun and a badge
i think it shows that
you can be unique too
there are cops with plenty of talents
and you know i'm surrounded by talent
within my squad department station
and
people don't see that and i hope that me
playing the violin
it
enables people to see a different side
of police officers
[Music]
i'm still working at getting better as a
violinist
but now i have the gun and badge and i'm
trying everything i can to serve the
community
serving and performing with a purpose
jan crawford cbs morning's bowie
maryland
thank you jan and he's got range too oh
he's got that talent for music for sure
but i like what he said that when you
get to see a police officer that there's
another side because they're human
beings too we all get that it's so nice
that you can see another side and it is
i can see why people look at him in the
uniform and go what yeah because just
the visual image is something that you
don't always in fact i've never seen to
be honest yeah they oftentimes see a
police officer say what is he armed with
what are they here for he's armed with a
violin yeah and he's here to lift your
spirits yeah i think a lot of people
like watching him play that violin in a
tank top too he's got the arms for law
enforcement he's got the guns
different definition to armed and
dangerous huh yes i know i get two guns
look at those arms very soothing and
very healing too sort of like nate your
guy nate yeah i'm